good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday that feels like a friday
because this is our last show of the
week jackie and i are both
heading out of town for some events that
we must partake in
it's very exciting it's a thursday that
feels like a friday and that's the sort
of energy that we're gonna bring
to you today like a little gotta get
down on thursday energy we've gotta get
down on thursday we've gotta free
brittany there's so much to do on the
docket today
there's that i'm actually feeling
overwhelmed i know and i'm
looking forward to it because there's
been a dearth there has been a dearth in
things to talk about and there's been a
surplus of mindlessness but we've been
making do with it we have been and it's
always so fun and like i
personally like you know the challenge
of finding stories outside of the movie
i know you do
um but there's a lot to talk about today
one the brittany stuff is just
mind-blowing like it's it's crazy how
much
we now know yes you know she speaks she
spoke and so we're gonna talk all about
that but also real housewives of beverly
hills
i really need to unpack how i'm feeling
yeah because i had a major
shift of heart i had i was going back
and forth like really
at one point i was like oh my god i take
back everything i said like
yes are you talking about crystal on
sutton no what are you talking about
erica
oh my god no that was community theater
at its finest i didn't even really give
any like i wasn't even listening because
whatever you're telling me it's a
[ __ ] lie
you didn't leave him because he didn't
say love you back when you dropped him
off at work you left him because he
stole money from widows and orphans and
you quite possibly knew about it like
that was literally acting i'm talking
about crystal and sutton like
i was so team crystal and like now i
just feel like
she's like like liking the attention of
like all this drama so she's like
prolonging it while saying she doesn't
want to be prolonging it yeah whatever
we'll get into it
right now you know i had a lot to say
about it and then i also watched fiesta
key which is just like such a good show
right now because
they made the most of kovid and they're
still in the grenade right
every week like new people come to the
island and it's from paradise no
literally it's bachelor in paradise but
it's all like former enemies
love that of theirs and kara do you
remember cara nose job
newly shot who never got a fair shake on
the show to begin with
who like she showed up and everyone
decided to be mean with her mean to her
without even giving her just because she
was with garrett
because she was with gary and she was
like friends with alex and then chloe
was like
like kind of egging her on to like being
mean to the other girls and i just felt
like she never got
a fair chance and i always like felt rdh
about the way it went down for her and
now she's back and
i'm so glad i'm so behind on yesterday
so i will
very much look forward to i only watch
the first two episodes this season i've
got to get my [ __ ] together
so i'm looking forward to hearing the
recap from your mouth to julian
sears yeah same thing god loves cst god
loves julia
um so we have a lot to do today and i'm
just feeling excited you know
i'm headed to vegas that's so exciting
and i'm just
like actually so excited to like be in a
casino like smell the cigarettes like
i'm just
i can't wait are you gonna gamble of
course i mean i don't have a lot of time
i'm literally in vegas for like 17 hours
but i
have a feeling i'll find some time yeah
leave it to me to find time that's
exciting for you yeah i love gambling
you really do i do you do you do um so i
feel like
we should jump right in because there's
actually a lot to cover
like musc and dilly dally and we've
dilly dallied long enough
i'll just um give one update which is
that i finished malibu rising
so good five stars oh it's really great
i just bought it on the kindle you're
gonna look for my plane today it was so
good
i also bought the new sally hepworth
book good sister is that what it's
called
so if i have time maybe one on the
flight there one on the flight back yeah
you could if you
good sister is a shorter read malibu
rising like felt long but i didn't want
it to end also it's two totally
different books the first half in the
second half
oh i hate that no no like it's the same
book but she just like
turned it around okay okay yeah no i
understand what you mean okay you know
yeah okay so i think without further a
do going back to saying it because it's
our show and these things make us happy
me at least and make us special we are
nothing if not special right so without
further ado
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and i pulled the people on your
instagram the people like the quirks
you're so quirky you are not like other
girls like at all
i know and you know who else isn't like
other other animals
the zebra i tried today's episode is
brought to you by the zebra think about
all the purchases you made in quarantine
pizza delivery succulents
then there's one of your biggest
purchases insurance americans overspend
on car and home insurance by billions
every year and that's money you could
have spent on more retail therapy or i
don't know patreon
that's where the zebra can help you the
zebra is the nation's leading insurance
company comparison site for car
and home insurance in minutes you can
compare policies from every major
provider for free all in one independent
marketplace after a few questions the
zebra pairs people with the right
insurance company for them
helping everyone save time and money
make insurance the smartest
your smartest purchase yet visit the
zebra.com
toast to get your free quote today visit
the zebra.com
toast for a free quote and don't
overspend on insurance there's so many
other things like food you could be
spending your money on
seriously i'll give you a list of things
oh she's a laptop girly today i'm on my
laptop today because
i forgot to charge my ipad i figured it
was charged and it wasn't and it just
didn't have
it didn't have the strength for the show
we talked about this like every few
months like i don't understand why you
don't leave your ipad here and just
charge it like every time you leave you
take it with you and of course you're
not gonna charge it at home
i do charge it at home i don't know it
just did you it just feels i guess i
could
maybe i'll try to start doing that but i
have a system
system works you know but the system
does fail like today
yes but i have my computer which i also
always have i always have a backup plan
and if if some reason my computer was
dead i would use my phone
yeah i when you um are gone and i have
to like be in charge of the show with
the co-host i do all the stories from my
phone and first of all like
chaos literally like my eyes get so
tired it's like tiny little font
and it just looks like if you're
watching on youtube like i'm on my phone
the whole time a hundred percent
it's like i couldn't be interested in
what like taylor's tracker has to say
because i'm just like reading text
no 100 and i think the laptop looks
pretty serious like yeah
what is she working on it's mr mccorkey
what's his name
mr mccorky picking up a kim
hi mr mccorkey kim where are you i'm
about to do my show
kim [ __ ] your little passion project
we've got villains to slay
mr mccory i'm so passionate
okay are you ready for our first story
like no more daily not unless we're
freeing britney
of course we are it's our first second
third fourth and fifth story okay just
kidding but it's the big one
britney spears conservative
conservatorship case
her full statement is here britney
spears spoke before a los angeles court
on wednesday
giving a fervent speech on the details
of her 13-year conservatorship
in her nearly 30-minute virtual address
before an la court and judge brenda
penny
the singer spoke out against her father
jamie spears and her management team
saying that she is quote traumatized and
her family
she kept referring to her family kind of
implying that like she lumps in her dad
with her mom and her sisters like
i was shook by that i really was i was
as well quote i've lied and told the
whole world i'm okay and i'm happy
i'm not happy i can't sleep i'm
depressed i cry every
every day shortly after the singer ended
asked to end the 13-year conservatorship
saying i just want my life back
it's been 13 years and it's been enough
there were so many takeaways from this
speech like so many bombshells came out
so many like shocking tidbits about what
she's been going through
and i think the most shocking thing at
least for me was the way that she spoke
because we're used to this voice she
puts on on instagram it's actually
concerning when you see it because it's
like oh this person is
maybe struggling because she's like
talking very strange she was
so coherent so articulate like she was
not at all like that weird kind of
persona she puts on on instagram
and like for me these were the craziest
bombshells one that they put an iud in
her and she can't get pregnant
because she said i just want to live my
life i want to marry my boyfriend and i
want to have babies and i
currently can't because someone put an
iud in me that's insane
two they put her on lithium which is
like the strongest drug in the world
that
she says she does not need yeah three
is that um oh
and this was like actually really crazy
to me because she has all these meetings
every week with like managers and
therapists and nurses
who she's paying but she didn't approve
she's like you have to meet with a
therapist you have to like them
they just make her go to therapy and if
she doesn't she gets punished and they
make her go to therapy in downtown l.a
and then they call the paparazzi so of
course
she leaves a forced therapy session very
emotional
the paparazzi gets pictures of her
crying in the middle of downtown l.a and
it continues this narrative that
brittany's unwell she needs the
conservatorship look she's struggling
when she's like just can i have the
therapist come to my house and can i get
it to be a therapist that i
like yeah and can i meet the therapist
once a week instead of three times a
week like
she's not even asking for anything so
crazy i just can't imagine like how
powerless it is to make all this money
and not only do you not have access to
it but other people are spending it on
your behalf yeah
that's infuriating in horrible awful
ways yes making you look
crazy yeah i can't i can't even imagine
there were so many like stories that she
shared even like
when she was rehearsing for her tour and
there was one dance move that she didn't
want to do and by the way she said that
she choreographed like her whole tour
she does the whole thing there was one
dance move that she didn't want to do
and they were like britney's being
difficult she won't um yeah comply with
what we need her to do
and they use that as an excuse and to
put her
on more medication right and with the
dance thing they said that like
all the dancers and all the people at
the choreography like session we're like
pretty so unwell like she can't
and then a video i think maybe sam took
it it's a video of brittany
at that choreography session where she's
leading it she's choreographing the
dance and she's showing it to everyone
and she's
so with it and she looks like she's
actually like having a good time like
there's just
like the conservatorship is problematic
for a million reasons but also
what i realized yesterday is like part
of the the conservatorship's like
biggest mission is to make brittany look
bad publicly so that the judge and just
the world doesn't think
that genie should get out of the
conservative like it's the best thing
for her yeah
i really i mean this has re like reached
a critical spotlight i really hope that
the judge and and the court system do
right by her like
we really like she needs freedom she's
not a free person no and
she's proven that she's very capable of
living in charge of her life
yeah and i like the other thing i took
away from her whole speech is like i
love sam ashkari like he's literally a
hero
she can't drive alone with him in a car
like she's legally were conservatorship
wise not allowed to get in a car with
him alone and i just feel like i kind of
wrote off their relationship
because like i don't know like i just
didn't think much of it but i actually
feel like we've gotten to the place that
we're at
with the help of sam schar like i think
he's really good for her yeah definitely
also they would like use her kids as
um like sort of like yeah bait to like
make her do stuff like if you don't do
this you won't be able to see your kids
but then they would put her somewhere
and she wouldn't be able to see her kids
and also like
where is hashtag where's kevin
fetterline i would absolutely love to
hear from him
yeah do you think he's part of the
conservatorship like because you have to
imagine all these people who are wanting
to keep
brittany in this conservatory are
benefiting from it financially of course
her dad is there's no doubt about that
i what it seems like it's like her whole
family is maybe kevin fetterline is too
like
why why would kevin fetterline
participate in that like
i don't know i i can't imagine he has
that much power no
situation unless he's getting you know
benefited from the conservatorship so he
just does what they said yeah
which i could see being a possibility
yeah probably so it was
crazy to hear her speak like in a real
voice yeah it was that
that was like the first big shock i
think what's even crazier is like this
whole free bit me thing up until really
yesterday it's been sort of like a
conspiracy idea
and you know there was the case that
like no she needs the conservatorship
brittany's okay like everyone is blowing
his head their protection
but then what she shared yesterday it's
actually so much worse
than i think anybody thought yeah me too
at first i was like
i mean that sucks but like she's you
know locked up in her mansion doing art
and
trying on clothes like how bad could it
be but it's really abuse like abuse
it's physical abuse putting like drugs
in her body that she doesn't consent to
putting an iud in her body it's control
it's literally like
hostage yeah it's crazy it's actually
like the craziest pop culture
development i feel like of our
generation like because it literally all
started with the podcast
yeah the movement the move yeah the
movement has been very grassroots
but i also feel like the movement and
the momentum and the documentary
that gave brittany like the strength to
speak on it like i feel like if there
wasn't this outcry from her fans from
the community
she might have just stayed silent yeah
or like if there wasn't this
huge interest you know she would have
spoken to a court but like this was a
ver like a virtual statement that you
know everyone was sharing through the
internet like this wasn't like a
broadcasted thing
no i thought that it was gonna be
broadcast i was literally on youtube
looking for the live
stream but it was not i read the
transcript i watched a video like
the free britney like stands were
outside the courthouse and there's like
a speaker outside the courthouse that
lets you hear what's going on inside
and somebody recorded that and put it on
twitter wow
like that's where the movement is so
important because if if there was less
interest in it then she just would have
given her speech to the court and the
judge like
like the judge did two years ago would
have shut her down but now they can't it
was a 30-minute speech
yeah and i wonder what is the timeline
like when do we hear
the verdict i do have like a small
amount of faith that the judge is a
woman i just feel like
women are more sympathetic but didn't it
wasn't she saying in the speech that
like this was the same she
pleaded with this judge two years ago
did she and shared so much of this and
nothing changed
you think the judge has seen like the
free britney documentary she probably
can't like
she has to remain completely impartial i
don't know if she's seen the documentary
but
i think she'll she's seen the headlines
this morning yeah i mean
it was powerful like i don't know how
you could be in the room like i watched
it
a video of a speaker and i was impacted
by it so i don't know how you could be
in the room and not like have just
enormous sympathy for her
and she's like what her lawyers are
asking is not for you know a new
conservator because that's what happened
this woman jody
who replaced her dad ended up being
worse and she's working with the dad and
that's what britney said in her speech
she was like jody like you were
there was a good development the last
time we reported on it like all right
the conservatorship is still in place
but at least it's not the dad anymore
it's
a court appointed jody and what britney
said is like jody's worse than anyone
else
she's like my life is hell so a new
conservator wouldn't even help
like the conservatorship just gotta go
yes no
like it's it's time it's time i agree
it's been 13 years like
and you know what they're a
conservatorship is basically like when
you don't think a person is able to take
care of themselves
someone comes in and you know controls
it for them
first of all britney seems fine and i
know people way worse off who are
literally in control of their own lives
so it's so stupid like so stupid but
also like
the fact it makes no sense one plus one
equals sock that she can go on these
tours and
and yes and support all these people she
said this too like
tours trucks residencies residencies
like all these things that she's doing
but she
can't even take care of herself but she
takes care of thousands of people for
sure
you know she's all of that sure jody
yeah sure
jody exactly like that's the thing it's
like well if she's so unwell
how was she literally like the most
successful vegas residency pop star like
it actually doesn't make sense
no that's such a good point too and she
made that point she
i just would have loved a little bit of
clarification on who runs the instagram
because i feel like it's not her she if
she doesn't have control of her life she
doesn't have control over instagram
so she might film content and have to
like submit it and they post it like
like like thinking they're tricking us
but like we're not
no not at all interesting
it's a crazy development we'll keep you
abreast i don't know when like a
judgment is coming but
i think we're all just really hopeful
and honestly if if we don't get like the
answer we're looking for like
it's just gonna be it's it's taken us 13
years to get to this point and i feel
like brittany is going to be broken
i don't see how we don't get the verdict
but i mean i know but like i don't know
what will happen because i really think
that
now everybody even people who like
weren't interested in this like are
now hearing no human being deserves to
be treated this way no it's really awful
and honestly like i just
feel like everyone in the all the
lawyers i just feel like everyone's paid
off
and that's what britney said she's like
they oh no i was watching rose mcgowan
did a segment on fox news about it and i
actually learned a lot from her
they paid off doctors in the beginning
of the conservatorship
to say that brittany had dementia
so can someone in dementia sing
literally for two hours straight
songs from 10 years ago right remember
all their lyrics and that's how they got
the conservative ship so everyone's been
paid off so like
if it doesn't go the way that we that it
should it's because like it's so corrupt
yeah but i think that the spotlight
on this puts pressure puts pressure and
all those like evil forces that work in
the dark are now have come to light
yeah well we are rooting for britney
constantly and you know what
got my gavel justice for chris crocker
who leave brittany alone
he's been talking about the free britney
movement before it was popular yeah he's
literally the first
free britney stan true justice for
brittany well of course yes
and if that if that judge brenda doesn't
use her gavel
to sway in the cause of justice like
this
i'll be very upset yeah and she doesn't
deserve to hold
this sacred mallard no mallard or mallet
sacred mallet right well i have my
computer too mallard is that thing from
sex in the city
that are all over trey and um mallet is
what we are and the mallard is like
those
duck things that are you know in
charlotte and trey's apartment
decorates it with all those ducks oh
yeah it's a duck
yeah it's a kind of duck that's really
funny yeah
i actually just watched an episode of
sex and city about the mallards so
that's why
i said mallard yesterday too got it you
were close
i'm so smart like it's disgusting okay
are you ready for our next story
i mean no i honestly like i feel like we
once we stopped talking about free
britney like we'd lose our momentum but
we do have to move on i just want to say
like
we support the free branding movement
and what's going on in our justice
system is a disgrace
disgrace towards the judicial branch of
this government disgrace towards the
word justice
literally okay but our next story is
also some big news of the day scooter
braun did a profile
in variety talking about his illustrious
career from you know
his beginnings till now and he was asked
a question about taylor swift and that's
every headline
in the news today because i read the
article and honestly like
if you can separate the scooter braun
from the taylor swift like
what scooter braun has built
business-wise is arguably one of the
most impressive impressive businesses in
hollywood he just got
acquired for a billion dollars by a
japanese company
his company is not even just talent
management it's merch it's
our virtual reality it's actually so
impressive and like the only thing
people care about from this article
is the taylor swift of it all because
honestly they're just contradicting each
other like how can it be
one plus one equal sock like scooter
never reached out to me i reached out to
taylor multiple times
which is it yeah so in a new profile for
variety the 40 year old music mogul
maintained that he offered swift every
opportunity to buy back
his masters her masters and said that he
sad about how his acquisition of taylor
swift's
master's recordings went over with the
singer he said i regret and it makes me
sad that taylor had
that reaction to the deal all of what
happened has been very confusing and not
based on anything factual
i don't know what story she was told i
asked for her to sit down with me
several times but she refused
i offered to sell her the catalog back
and went under nda but her team refused
it all seems very unfortunate i feel
like this is like a little bit of like
gaslighting like
i'm sorry that it went that way and he
said like you know me and taylor only
met a few
times before this and it was like very
civil well that's like really
gaslighting because like let's talk
about like the public thing like
you know the screenshot with kanye
justin bieber like there was more this
time the face time yeah
there was more than just like a few
casual meetings like you can't
understand you might not agree but you
can't understand why taylor doesn't like
you
yeah he but when he said the thing like
offered to go
sell her the catalog and wanted to go
under nda because that's what you do
when like you're going into an agreement
it harks back to when she said in
november 2020 that he requested she
signed an nda
that would silence her forever yeah and
that's where
two things can be true just from two
different
people's point of view there was an nda
on the table taylor saw
it as silencing her forever scooter saw
it as
the introduction to a business deal
that's true actually like
perspective it's so i think both of
their
povs can be rooted in what actually
happened but
like anything else they see it
differently yeah
honestly like i didn't really care about
this
the taylor parts of the article because
like i stand with my girl taylor like
whatever she tells me i believe like i
really do
but i think what what people are missing
from this article is like
his business is so impressive and he got
acquired for a billion dollars to which
he profited about 400 million
and he gave over 40 people like
millions of dollars in stock
one he gave it to like justin bieber and
ariana who like really built the company
like if it weren't for them
he wouldn't have much credibility he
gave it to like certain people at the
company
who started with him people who like
were early employees i thought that was
really cool
yeah really cool i think if you read the
article you'll have it if you've only
heard about scooter braun like from the
taylor swift masters drama i think
you'll have
a whole new world of context around him
as a business person
and i think in the saga between him and
taylor i think that it was a
feather in his cap you know what what do
you think one point for scooter yeah i
mean taylor's obviously like in the
public narrative has won
this argument scooter is the villain he
stole her masters
and i think that the article as a whole
is just one one small win for scooter
oh yeah i mean i do think this is all
part of and he says like
the journalist asked him like you became
like this villain like does it bother
you what people think about you
and his answer was like very generic
like with you know with success comes
you know all different types of
perceptions about you and controversy
which is true
but i do think he's deeply bothered by
like the
the narrative that's been said about him
because he probably believes it to not
be true
yeah also i think for like up until the
taylor swift stuff like he was very
like a b to b guy like if you're in the
industry you know scooter brawn like you
have so much respect for him and like
the taylor swift up made him like so b
to c like everyone
he's a celebrity and his like public
facing self now is just
associated with this like that's so true
people don't even think about like the
the business like what he did for like
the 10 years before taylor swift
yeah and also i mean i do think it's
interesting how so many of his clients
have such wonderful things to say about
him when i read the story yesterday and
then i read the britney transcript and
her talking about like
her shitty management team and i was
like i think she needs to be managed by
scooter
well that's what scooter said about the
taylor thing he was like it meant a lot
to me that all the people like demi and
ariana justin they all stood by him and
he feels like that was
validation for him that like he was
right
and honestly like that's that's fair
but i stand with taylor but i still have
respect for
the business yeah it's actually if the
article is super interesting if you like
if you hate scooter like you're just
gonna hate it but if you're interested
in the business of
hollywood it's super interesting yeah
and how he got acquired and this
i forget his name but like the the ceo
of the japanese company that acquired
him like
became his mentor to him and gave him
like such great pieces of advice and
it was actually an interesting article
from that i didn't even care about the
taylor stuff because honestly
i'm really not interested in hearing any
other side than taylor's like i could
just sama taylor
like i believe what she said happened
and i believe taylor
okay um also i thought another
interesting thing that he said because
they asked about justin bieber going
back on tour because like his last
his two tours ago he cancelled 14 shows
yeah before didn't sell got cancelled
because of covington
so they said literally it was arenas
and then they like downgraded to
stadiums and then thankfully like
coveted was a good excuse for them
they're like oh we just have to cancel
all them
that like doesn't make sense to me
because justin bieber think about before
the pandemic like he was in a weird
place
and literally during the pandemic it was
bop after bop after bob and
i would not miss a justin bieber concert
right now yeah a year ago like you
couldn't pay me yeah that's true anyways
he talked about how like
him being with haley on tour oh because
they were like i don't get anything
because he doesn't because justin
doesn't have a good experience with
touring really yeah so they were like
what will be different for the next tour
like how
what makes you sure that like it's going
to go well and he was like well he has
haley by his side now like someone who
really has his back and
he's going to be with him at every
single stop and yeah she's just a really
good
partner for him so i thought that was
really nice i saw the purpose tour with
like the trampolines
i mean it was stunning but like he was
jumping around on a trampoline and like
was not singing
i saw the one i think it was probably
purpose it's the chris like is that
his first like christian-ish album yeah
i loved that album
yeah i saw it recently like five years
ago so i think it was purpose it was
good but he wasn't singing
yeah no he was jumping around on a
trampoline
yeah okay ready for our next story only
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by newm
it is when it comes to losing weight
there's a lot of pressure to find out
sorry there's a let me start again i had
a little burp when it comes to losing
weight there's a lot of pressure out
there to label foods as good or bad
but that just creates unnecessary
dilemmas nume is here to change how we
see food with a psychology-based
approach that looks at what you eat but
also how you eat
instead of making you feel guilt or
regret noob empowers you to keep
going you don't need rules to lose
weight just the knowledge and wisdom to
help you build smarter more sustainable
habits
noom's cognitive behavioral approach
helps you unlearn bad habits and better
understand your relationship with food
one size does not fits all one size does
not fit all
choose your goals a new will personalize
a weight loss program just for you
eighty percent of new users finish the
program and over 60 percent have stuck
with their goals for at least a year
you have been on the new yeah
for a really long time now yeah for a
few years now and what's your favorite
part
my favorite part is just the consistency
of it it just really feels like even no
matter how far you stray like noom is
always
there it's never too late to get back on
noom and to let them know what you've
been up to like noon and noom doesn't
judge
yeah which is my favorite thing unlike
me like they know they know that you're
living too
yeah girls gotta eat start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial
at noom.com toast that's n-o-o-m-dot-com
toast thank you for that claudia you are
unbelievably welcome
okay next story netflix gives a
two-season order to the dating
show sexy beasts with catastrophe star
rob delaney as the narrator
great like literally moronic shows left
right and center no season two of the
society i will never stop bringing it up
right we get two seasons of sexy beasts
which is
actually just like the mask dater it's
the math singer meets love is blind
yeah where these people are going on
dates in elaborate
masks like not just like you know a face
mask like no it's the best singer
they look like mascots it's like
prosthetics and everything if you watch
the trailer it's like so ridiculous it
actually looks like that commercial
for that yes where that match.com the
girl is going
on dates with um twenty dead bunny the
devil and satan in 2020 are going on a
date together that's what it is
yes exactly that's what the trailer for
the show looks like
and now it's coming to netflix it is two
seasons which see singles heading into
blind age transformed into various
animals and mythical creatures
through the use of hollywood movie
prosthetics the show is based on lion
tv's original british series
for the digital bbc three in 2014.
can i tell you why it sounds stupid
because love is blind for me why we
loved it so much and the whole world
loved it one because it was quarantined
and we had nothing to do
no actually it wasn't quarantine it was
before i take that back why we liked it
so much was because
it was finally like a serious dating
show like the bachelors become so like
like kitschy like love is blind was so
real we got amber and barnett like we
really
developed real relationships from it it
was a journey and it was like a crazy
experiment
but it was still very serious lauren and
cameron like they were
and this just feels like it's doing the
love is blind template but taking the
seriousness out of it
it's so ridiculous i mean
i'm sure they'll they'll have like real
couples from and i think because it's
netflix they have the time to really
like develop
these relationships and based on the
trailer like it looks like people may be
following yeah
but just like how can you watch this
with a straight face no i know and like
honestly
what's really getting me like all bent
out of shape about it
is how they just like kind of with this
dumb idea like strolled into two seasons
and we couldn't even i'm sorry i'm never
gonna stop bringing it up like why we
couldn't get a second season of the
society it's so disgraceful like the
society was literally
i want to say like one of the smartest
best most compelling shows of our
generation
for young for the young sect yeah no i
think all people like it too it's
fascinating
such an interesting concept great acting
yeah no it was so good and i just i
agree we can confirm two seasons of this
but we couldn't confirm two seasons of
this
and i think they actually did confirm
two seasons of the society and then like
after it was launched and everyone loved
it
they decided to take the second one away
like i just want to know what happened
like
newton piss off like what happened it
was one of the coveted casualties and i
think that like netflix
i think they made the wrong choice and
i'm still holding out hope that they
will correct what they did
or like someone pick it up like it's
just it's really not okay is what picks
up shows that were like
unrightfully canceled and if they had
said it was just a one season kind of
thing like queen's gambit and like the
end was left up to interpretation like
we could have you know lived with that
but the fact that they giveth and then
take it the way
that's what most hurt me no it hurts so
bad and then it hurts more when you see
this idiot like this yeah moronic i'll
probably watch it but still
maybe no honestly the only thing is that
netflix actually does a really good job
at reality shows right and like i don't
even watch the circle because i watched
first episode and i thought it was like
kind of silly
people love it like people really do
love these like stupid and even i
thought the math singer was such a dumb
[ __ ] idea the first time i saw it i'm
like
this is not gonna last it is a cultural
phenomenon so like maybe we're wrong but
it looks so stupid like
i really can't do this today like it's a
lot yeah it's a lot i agree
like i'm dealing with brittany like i'm
dealing with a lot and then you have to
see like
this moronic lunacy yeah i agree
and actually if you watch a trailer
which you should like it really looks
like an
snl parody of a show yeah like the
masked dater like
a joke when is telling sunset coming
back i hopefully soon
do you see krishnel bought a three
million dollar house like yes crochet no
i didn't where is it
it's so nice honestly it looks nicer
than like one justin hartley might be
able to afford you know
where is it plus they were living in the
valley before is it in the valley
um i'm really not clear on the geography
of
la like to me the whole thing is beverly
hills but like that's just not true
i'm not clear on it either but selling
sunset got me to a clearer place which
is like there are the hills which like
wrap around a million times i know the
hills they're
literally also like in if you're just
thinking of geography like where there
is a hill there's most likely a
valley i mean that's such a good call
but like when i used to watch tv shows
like okay
cher when her dad called her and she was
at a party in the valley he was like are
you in the valley like the valley sounds
like great
literally and then like an entourage to
go down to the valley and it was um
a power outage and they were so hot and
they went to that party like the
valley's always like considered bad but
now like all the vanderpump rules kids
live in valley village
i'm just confused that's why if you
watch selling sunset and krishele became
their like
valley ambassador the valley's really
coming up and you can get a little bit
more land i think it's great for family
so she probably moved to the valley if
you want to just google christelle's
staff's house it's so nice like the
backyard looks like
a farm chairman dream like so much open
air like views that's
like very valley-ish yeah she probably
does live in the valley she couldn't be
like the valley spokesperson for the
oppenheim group and not live in the
valley 100
i think she was really passionate about
the valley i don't think she was putting
on and who better than us understands
passions
hollywood hills disgrace absolute
disgrace
that's really upsetting oh my god this
house is [ __ ] stunning i know right
and she did it all by herself like i'm
actually really happy for her wow she
got that dancing with the stars bunny
that's selling sunset and netflix money
i'm really excited for the next season
of selling sunset because
christine is just yeah most interesting
woman
i'm gonna need mary and roman like not
to return in order to make the show
watchable what the show giveth
christine christine yeah they take it
away mary
i totally agree okay are you ready for
our next story it's like some random
news
sure wow way to sell it yeah sorry
like jerry seinfeld is doing a pop-tarts
origin movie for netflix but we still
don't get society season two
wait what origin story it's not a
cartoon it's a
snack he's doing like a show about
how they got their star jerry seinfeld
is set to star
write direct and produce a pop tarts
origin story
inspired by one of his routines okay now
is it animated netflix has acquired the
rights to the comedy feature film
unfrosted which will tell the story of
the invention of the sugary breakfast
pastry
the invention of pop-tarts i don't think
my father the inventor of toaster
strudel would be too happy to hear about
this
yeah okay i just want to say it sounds
incredibly stupid like so did b-movie
and that movie
was so compelling i literally cried b
movie sounded stupid i don't think so a
movie about
bees yeah it did and jerry seinfeld
literally knocked that [ __ ] out of the
park better than any episode of seinfeld
i've ever seen in my life sorry i said
it
and i'm i'm honestly not gonna knock
this until i
at least see a trailer i don't know how
many people like need to hear the story
of like
how the pop tart was invented but like i
really i think it could be if it's like
scripted like a show that sounds cool if
it's gonna be like
all those shows on food network which is
like how
you know they on food network they're
always doing like little documentary
episodes about like how
unwrapped unwrapped yeah that's the best
show ever if this is going to be
unwrapped like i'm good but if it's
going to be like a scripted
fiction i think it is that sounds cool
yeah
i mean i mean is this story worth
telling i don't know the origin of pop
tarts but you know what story is worth
telling
the second season of the society
um wait i had one more thing to say
about this
moronic idea and that was
what were you talking about jerry
seinfeld a little bit earlier
unwrapped yeah right before the society
right before that
movie b-movie seinfeld comedians and
cars
no what are we getting at the season of
that i don't know i don't know it looks
like they could use some first comedians
i need an i need another season of that
because sometimes i forget that
um comedy is more personal than food and
it's so important that jeremy reminds
you that all the time
all the time honestly i don't think this
is such a bad idea like i might watch us
yeah who knows i mean you never know
i've watched worse things you know
yeah i watched the big shop with bethany
like i can handle anything
justice for that show was so good well
speaking of comedians and cars getting
coffee
our fifth and final story is a new study
that's great news for coffee lovers
oh you know me obsessed yeah coffee
lovers are almost 50 percent
less likely to die from chronic liver
disease a new study says
it's so dark like turns out that extra
coffee might end up saving your life
so it's good that you're on the coffee
grind now claudia i feel like
since oh i remember what i was going to
say i remember
it's so random like it honestly makes no
sense i don't even want to say it
but now you have to so like in the like
fifth grade do you remember like having
to do a project where like everyone had
to
do like a whole origin story on how
something was invented you know everyone
like did the light bulb or like
something like the microwave
i chose and this has to do with pop
tarts i chose i
don't know why i chose the um
the waffle cone like i wanted to figure
out like
who invented the waffle cone and what
made it so difficult is like there's
actually a really kind of confusing
origin story on the waffle cone and
um it's actually not even clear like
there's rumors that it happened at a
world fair like somebody took a waffle
put it in the cone
there's really no confirmation on how it
actually started but the whole point of
the project is to
detail the origin story of a certain
product
um and then my teacher called my parents
and i got in trouble for choosing the um
waffle cone and i had to go with the
light bulb so i just think
i hope jerry doesn't run into that
problem with the pop tarts
i think that he probably has a down pat
hopefully it's clear like
yeah but i can imagine that you should
have just gone with who invented the
waffle
you know i just like wanted to i'm not
like other girls so i just wanted to be
creative and like everyone was doing
like such
obvious like the kite like we know is
benjamin franklin you know like no
he didn't meant the kite he invented the
electricity with the kite you know what
i mean like everyone was just doing like
textbook idiocy like the phone alexander
graham bell duh like we knew that
i just wanted to be different because
i've never been like other girls and i
chose the waffle cone and
it literally this project like tortured
me in the fifth grade like for months
i could see why you should have either
chosen like the waffle or the ice cream
cone
i just wish that there was an episode of
unwrapped that would have detailed how
the waffle cone got started so i could
have just plagiarized it for my paper
yeah well if you had figured it out and
you enjoyed a waffle cone you should
have had a cup of coffee with it
well so that's what else what i was
going to say i just feel like there's
all these studies like i've been reading
i've been hearing about studies it's
always on the local news
and they like never come true like it's
like
projection no it's like i agree don't
live your life based on this one study
but if you're currently a coffee drinker
like that's good news for you
like don't don't be so worried about
your habit no i'm
i'm not worried at all i just i refuse
to live my life by these studies like i
really do and they're just constantly
you have to live your life for you yeah
and not for the scientists no and
no you like if you want a cup of coffee
you have one if you don't don't
chars but now that you're joining the
coffee club i figured you'd want to hear
this bit of good news that you're doing
something for your health
it's good because pretty much everything
else i do in my life um
chips away at my health like i'm 26 with
the body of definitely like a 97 year
old based on just like how much i drink
and like
don't sleep and eat like an animal so
that's good
yeah it's always good to hear you're
taking care of yourself yes so congrats
claude
thank you the scientists really did this
one for me i feel like yeah the
scientists in their studies you know
so that was the final story and i
definitely feel as though you needed to
know most of them
yeah no you needed to know most of them
um let's dive into the tv recap segment
which is brought to you by
hair food hair food offers simple
superfood inspired products that will
make your hair look and feel amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and try spice collection
you've
gotta try some of their new recipes the
apple cider vinegar herons is perfect
for days when your hair needs a gentle
cleanse before conditioning i literally
need to do that when i get home
the turmeric and almond oil detangling
milk takes care of the most stubborn
knots and it reduces frizz because
detanglers are not just for children the
shea butter and pear color repair
concentrate makes over processed hair
look vibrant
and healthy they all smell so good and
they are certified pita cruelty free
so if you're looking for nourished
healthy hair it's gotta be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
the results are legit my hair has been
the detangler is truly working miracles
on my hair and the um
apple cider vinegar hair rinse is so
good for your hair like it really
detoxes all the crap out of it amazing
thank you for that claude you're welcome
let's talk about real housewives of
beverly hills because we finally got to
hear from erica exactly what's been
going on
i agree with the women that she
definitely had like a much lighter
spirit to her but if i didn't know all
that i know now i would have thought
last night's episode was so interesting
so sad she's so brave she's so
courageous oh her new house is so sad
i know what i knowing what i know now
from the housewife and the hustler and
just like what's been going on in the
news like
i couldn't even watch this performance
like acting like
they got divorced for any other reason
besides the lawsuits is so inauthentic
and it's such a lie but i do feel like
for her own court appearances like she
has to keep it up
the story that she they got divorced and
i like if she admitted that she actually
released it on election day
to try and bury it like i appreciate the
transparency i appreciate that too i
don't know like
i feel like we said this season like she
needs to explain to us what happened
there's still some like there's still
some wiggle room for her to
let us know that she didn't know but i
feel like until the lawsuits become a
subject on the show
she's not going to bring them up so
until we get there like i still
can't believe fully but i felt like we
got way more last night than i expected
to
considering it's erica and how much like
legality is going on behind it
and i'm really really curious
yeah and also like i don't know just
some things weren't really adding up
because like she
i feel like every time i mean obvious of
course if you're in a marriage and like
you guys are together you're not going
to always talk about like the negative
things but i felt like
for so long it seemed like they had the
best marriage like tom was her biggest
cheerleader well
and so for now her to say that like she
he treated her like an
employee i can like
it just is so in congress with
everything that we
that we saw well i had forgotten about
erica's first season where tom was
actually pretty active on the show and
they gave us a few clips
he used to like snap at everybody i
forgot about that oh my god i
i don't know i completely i hadn't i had
never killed it i had never seen that
before when they played the
footage of like him snapping at lisa
vanderpump i remember that but i
remember him snapping at erica
i was like what did we ever see that
because that's not the time that ever
came through on the show
he has been rehabilitated image-wise on
the last few seasons after his first
season they took him out and only showed
him like once a season and he was
so supportive helping her sign her
broadway contract inviting the ladies
over to their parlor and giving them
drinks and telling funny stories about
aaron brockman
i never i never knew that his image on
the show needed to be rehabilitated i
remember that first season
no i don't remember him ever coming off
badly oh i do and when he snapped at
them i'm like
oh that's the man on the phone that's
the voicemail guy yes that's sociopath
tom
i remember i i remember it happening but
i had completely forgotten about it
until they flashed back and it was a
gentle reminder that like he's actually
a bad person
yeah that was crazy i had completely
forgotten about that
her new house is it's nice for
someone but like going from the palace
to the palisades or whatever like
it is uh a huge shift and honestly
her assistant and mickey or mikey
whatever his name is um
being like oh my god it's gorgeous like
they're being very supportive at night
it's like oh my god it's going to be
stunning yeah girl it's a rental um
no i thought the house was really cute
and also like
given if this were just you know she's
leaving her super wealthy husband
and this is her new house like that's
not what it is it's like she's leaving
the [ __ ] scandal of the century like
she'd rather be in this house than in a
prison cell she's fleeing and this is
like supposed to be a temporary thing
and i think that if it weren't for the
lawsuits this would be the place that
she would chill out until she gets her
settlement
camille grammar testile and then gets
to spend her money how she pleases but
there's no money to get like she would
should if they just got divorced thomas
said he at one point he had 80 million
dollars and now he doesn't have anything
yeah so i don't know what erica's gonna
do financially if she gets out of this
i think that i think she well if she
gets out of it
one like legally and also i don't know
there's so much that has to happen
before
before the judgment is made do you know
what i mean yeah so i'm just like
taking every piece of information like
adding it to the puzzle
the the board of trying to understand
the housewife and the hustler
and i felt like more information yeah we
need more
information i just i don't know because
it's like if
for 20 years like their relationship was
this way of like him
treating her like an employee and like
so condescending even though that's not
what it seemed like
but then why leave now right you say you
were going to hold this man's hand till
he died and it's always been this way
why did you leave today that's that
moment could potentially be around the
corner he's very old
well and apparently according to the
courts he has dementia or alzheimer's
yeah
so it's just all very confusing and
there's so many lies and all the women
are believing what erica says because
they don't know what we know yet so it's
like frustrating it's like ask more
questions
no but that's why i'm waiting for the
lioness suit to become public in
real time because we do have that scene
of dory talking about the orphans and
widows
and we do have the scene of garcelle
asking erica like is that why you got
divorced i think we'll get there
in time it's just moving a little slowly
for me
okay and then for me for the rest of the
episode i actually found that to be like
slightly more interesting just because
like this erica stuff
knowing what i know now it's like girl
you could lie and say like he didn't
tell you he loved you like that's not
why
but i found this sutton and crystal
thing to be so interesting because i
really sided with crystal and tahoe
because like sutton is weird and i can
imagine her coming into a group and like
sun's just being weird
crystal's dragging it out so much and
then like complaining that it's still
happening when it's like literally still
happening because you won't stop talking
about it
and i really feel like i disagreed a lot
with garcelle last week but i thought
this week garcelle was really
very poignant like okay sun was acting
weird she wasn't being mean to anyone
until she was just having like a few off
days and so
for crystal to call her manic and crazy
is like so dramatic and you just
shouldn't be calling other women that
and then when sutton pointed out like
those words are so triggering for her
because her dad committed suicide which
she had conveyed
to chris so i'm like you know what
you're actually right like crystal's
being way dramatic no i
was glad to see sutton standing up for
herself because i think in tahoe she
like realized like
oh her crazy showing like i'm just gonna
you know apologize and we're gonna try
and smooth this over but then like
when the word violated started being
thrown around it became like so much
bigger
than it needed to be and then sutton
like really stood her ground i was happy
to see her do that because
it was so unnecessary the whole thing
and i agree
the whole time i was like on crystal
side because i feel like in that
situation like i can imagine feeling
like
you would be the crystal i really really
would and i would 100 and i would feel
so [ __ ] awkward
but they need to move on yeah and i
really feel like sutton has like sutton
has not
she was glad that she accepted her
apology sutton hasn't been speaking
about it to anyone and there's just like
a million clips of like crystal
[ __ ] well i'll ask i'm gonna answer but
if you really wanted to get past it if
somebody asked you you would say
honestly we've gotten past it and i
don't want to rehash it like that's a
very normal thing to say
or like it wasn't a big deal but like i
can imagine if dorit the way she
described what happened to darie
what's so true what happened while she
was talking to reed if dorite were to
watch the scene like that's not the
the she dramatized she dramatized and
she
like sutton said one thing but crystal
was like she said something she made me
feel weird
as if they were all separate things but
it's just the one thing that she said
that made her feel weird that was like
awkward
yeah and crystal was definitely you know
completely
valid in her feelings the next morning
and i started with crystal because
sutton was being weird but sudden
apologized immediately it's doing her
best to move forward and crystal like
won't let it go yeah and she keeps
complaining that everyone's still
talking about it it's like
you you were still talking about it yeah
so that's where
my focus for the episode was um i
thought the evening at crystals looked
so lovely and was so nice to see
all the women devouring food because i
feel like this group really doesn't eat
and they were like living for the
dumplings and they looked so good they
looked really good
i was starving watching the episode like
so hungry
um but other than that like nothing else
really happened
this whole kyle and everything i
honestly don't even want to talk about
because it's so stupid
and kyle's so wrong yeah and i'm glad
she changed her tone
yeah from if you want to be my friend
you can't speak to me like that
shut up like seriously i hate when
people say that like don't talk to me
that way it's like [ __ ] i'm gonna talk
to you however the [ __ ] i want like i
hate when people say that
especially when jory like literally
didn't say anything crazy no
not at all so that's that on that siesta
key
siesta key okay so people are coming to
the island
and what i mean i'm really enjoying the
coward stuff i need some more people to
forgive her
juliette has forgiven her because also
like julia can't fight this war on so
many friends juliet needs allies
and i can like i really appreciate that
she
knows that and so i'm really enjoying
the friendship between
cara juliet and madison is also cool
with kara too um kelsey had her swimwear
photo shoot and it just i got really sad
because i know
because like everyone was like biting
and the sun was going down and like she
wasn't getting all the shots
did you get your jmp label bathing suit
i got my jmp the label bathing suit i
sent claudia
a picture sexy bikini photo i sent
claudia like a sexy bikini shot
and it is so good really
and the material is really good and it
like holds everything i was really
impressed i'm gonna wear it this weekend
and i just felt like it was really it
could work for anybody
love that i really do so i was really
impressed with jmp the label and i'll
i'll like post pictures this weekend
myself you know
like a bikini pick is a scary scary
scary scary thing
don't commit don't commit to the
beginning no but like
maybe i can finesse something a throng
[Laughter]
um what else happened julian and sam are
really cute
and again he's like so unnatural on
camera which we love to see
love to see a humble man yeah we really
do
and i guess that's like i'm trying to
think what else happened julia's upset
that like kelsey is like using the trip
to do her photo shoot that is annoying
for her bathing suit and like the more
that i think about it i really wish that
julian and kelsey
could have gotten along and launched
just one swimsuit line together
because it would have been like the
siesta key swimmer like that would have
been amazing but they just you know
maybe they'll be a merger in the future
i don't think so they're like so against
each other but also kelsey really like i
feel like for so many seasons she was
just sort of like happy to be
the supporting actor and like she just
woke up and it's like i
am the character i actually really see
that and i completely agree
and that's always the worst type of
reality star the one who thinks that
they're the star when they're so clearly
not
but she's like she has she's doing
everything she's
she's taking it on sure sure she could
be pop like
she's never going to be juliette well
juliet is the full-time narrator now
like remember in the beginning every
episode it was like
by someone else and now it's totally
juliet also chloe
has quit the show yes which i haven't
really noticed her absence
i feel like she was always fanning the
flames of drama which is why she wanted
to quit because she didn't know how to
stop doing that it was making her like
that's the best person um and it is for
the best because like
i just want to see these things develop
the way that they normally would because
these without someone
yeah like crazy and interesting they
don't need to manufacture drama
so glad to see kara back i hope that she
can make amends with more
people she's doing like a pretty good
job so far i'm like every time she goes
to apologize to someone she's like so
you know like kind of humbling herself
in earnest but like the minute she gets
pushed back she just turns into such a
[ __ ] i feel that a hundred percent no
it's like okay i tried
no she's like listen don't mistake my
humility for weakness like i'm just
trying to move on and if you can't like
[ __ ] you
yeah i fully respect that um all right
so good i really need to catch up on
that maybe i'll
download it on my ipad it's really um
it's really good this season and this
island situation is just such a good
idea
yeah well that's our show unfortunately
it's our final show of the week
so we'll be back monday with you know
hopefully some good news in the free
britney movement
and hopefully um some mindful news and
if you want more content from us you can
always head to patreon.com because
there's so much content there
ready and willing to get you through the
weekend so thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we live
with the best five stories that you need
to know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitch or public video i
have already cast box all the places so
we're able to listen to podcasts find us
morning shows leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
have an amazing weekend you guys will
see you on monday bye